alors je me présente je m'appelle gérard
giroudon je m'appelle dominique blanc je
m'appelle christophe mentonnaise je
m'appelle denis podalydès je m'appelle à
nasser bin cas je m'appelle eric
génovèse chez les espoirs
je suis loïc corbery je m'appelle serge
bagdassarian je m'appelle laurent
stocker et je suis le 511e sociétaires
je suis à la comédie française depuis 15
ans maintenant
[Musique]
il
et l'avenue française pour moi c'est
représente un peu ça qui va long de la
pléiade
c'est le premier théâtre de france et
premier théâtre national c'est le
premier théâtre public un lieu pour les
grandes oeuvres un lieu de grande
qualité
je crois que c'est une troupe qui un
rayonnement assez solaire voilà décide
pas de rentrer à la commune français
langue on vient vous vous cherchez
quand le téléphone sonne et qu'on vous
appelle pour l'instant dans cette maison
on se pose pas vraiment la question ça
ne se refuse pas
alors j'ai dit oui
j'ai fait vingt ans d'intermittence et
au bout de ses 20 ans m'a proposé de
rentrer à la comédie française qui était
absolument improbable et pour moi
comédie française c'est une grande
histoire d'amour faire partie de maisons
car il ya tout se passe et tout cet
avenir c'est quelque chose de
prestigieux blanc sur plus qu'une chance
puisqu'un prestige c'est plutôt un
sentiment de responsabilité de continuer
à être à la hauteur de 2 de l'histoire
de cette maison
oui j'ai un côté prestigieux mais nous
soyons peau il ya d'autres grands
théâtres on se rend compte que c'est un
endroit unique mais oui parce qu'on est
en droit d'en attendre beaucoup même si
c'est un endroit anciens ont fait du
théâtre de façon tout à fait moderne
mais les deux sont pas incompatibles
institutions et modernité c'est pas
parce qu'on joue des textes anciens
dater
au répertoire de textes répertoire comme
molière marivaux que c'est pas moderne
pour autant mais évidemment il n'y a pas
de mise en scène d'oeuvre du passé sans
qu'elle soit ou présent saisit pas du
tout de faire du du théâtre historique
tel qu'on faisait il ya longtemps mais
du fait de faire du théâtre
d'aujourd'hui dont c'est un théâtre
complètement dans la modernité
excellence des comédiens excellence des
textes excellence des auteurs
est-ce qu'on peut rajouter théâtre
l'audace le collectif pour nous c'est la
maison c'est une troupe troupe
alternance répertoire répertoire
alternance troupes
je crois que c'est une grande histoire
d'amour entre molière qui commence et
puis tous ces acteurs après on n'est pas
très loin molière en fin de compte à
molliet il ya son buste en bas devant
lequel passent chaque matin et on lui
tapote un pelage ou en partant après
chaque représentation ou molière c'est
une sorte de logo tirer les régions le
gardien de la maison comme la porte
d'orléans à paris c'est par là où
souvent on entre dans ton dans paris par
la porte d'orléans la part d'une des
portes par lesquelles on entre dans le
théâtre
[Musique]
i